so i was like
finally about to finish
and then
right before i finish i go
oh my god
every
woman i've ever dated is my father oh
yeah i mean i'm surprised it really took
you that long to get there they're
they're all
stephanie's or you know they're all like
named close to your dad they all have
temper issues i couldn't believe it i
was like they all drove audis
wow
i'm in love with oh hey did it work is
it finally working oh my god is it
working
you guys should let us know when you're
here oh thank god you let us know
when does the stream start thank
goodness
that the stream has begun so that we can
stop talking intimately okay good we're
doing it did it we're doing it next i
don't even want to talk about that new
cables let's change the stream guys
let's change the stream
greetings and salutations ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the best damn movie
show on the planet i'm your host john
campbell with me as always is my co-host
robert meyer burnett
how do we pick our main topics here on
the john campbell show was very similar
it's very simple i know what i want to
talk about already and i select the
questions that are going to feed that
and then i pick people's questions who
match with my already chosen times
yes and i mention the name of the show
as many times as i can oh gosh
all right guys look let's get into this
you guys you you dictate um oh it is not
turned on
yep
yeah
just stop what the fudge complaining
this is the sec
live in total 10 minutes and you've
probably merely come out all of these
things primarily complaints i'm
flummoxed all these things were as they
were supposed to be jeez i made sure we
are no longer
symbiotic no i know
you're just the suit all right guys look
you guys eddie brock is you oh my our
instagram's down too i'm not able to
share this and which really bummed me
out because that's where everything
comes from but yeah instagram is down
yeah guys let's talk about uh venom let
there be carnage let's get real honest
i've had quite a bit of i had a long
conversation with someone yesterday who
loved this movie and then i had an
equally um
long conversation with someone who
really didn't like this movie so it's i
feel like i've gotten a pretty good
amount of
like a variety of opinions on this but
really quick in the live stream chat
let's hear it what would you guys give
this like out of a rating from like one
to ten or do the letter grading from
like a plus to to f
minus
where would you personally put it just
put it down in the chats right there so
we're gonna pop this chat out yeah
there's absolutely a way
oh venom two is a four out of ten four
out of ten you're not
loving it two nine out of ten there you
go nine out of ten all right okay so
we're getting to i feel like most people
probably really like this movie i feel
like a lot of people are at least having
fun with it but uh there is a very vocal
uh you know
contingency of people who are not about
it i hear if you went okay whoa see
b-plus i see a six out of ten six seven
jaby said i hated it speaking for
himself he really hated it i have things
to appreciate about it that negative
nancy ernesto ramirez gave it a d look
it's mainly positive here all right so
time to get some crap
what i would say is um
it was funny having this conversation
with
uh with two people yesterday and then
finally the question was presented to me
of what would i have wanted this movie
to ultimately be like because
i feel i'm usually the kind of viewer
who watches something and goes
what are they giving me and let me
assess
that experience yeah as opposed to
putting my own rewrites on it
and then sometimes though you can't help
it you know i think we all do that i
think every single one of us is a little
bit guilty of going here's probably what
would have made this movie a little bit
better overall
um what's going on joe what should we
talking about
nah nah nah don't don't tell them that
they'll figure it out all right
that that sounds desperate you don't
know what john was about to type
well somebody said somebody in the chat
one person john
one pro we're gonna answer to everyone
now yeah
yeah that's what we do anyway
specifically what we do here
um
i think okay look really quick i do
really like tom hardy a lot in this i
love venom in it and uh i did like the
effects of carnage i do feel that
ultimately all the best shots of carnage
were already used in the trailer
and i did laugh quite a bit like i'll be
honest um the way they what they have
done with venom here i found
particularly humorous and appealing
where i think some people can be a
little bit split on that like i know
jeremy jones i watched his uh both of
his reviews on this and he was saying
how he
uh didn't want like an odd couple movie
and i didn't expect to walk into that in
fact that was something that kind of
surprised me was
when you see the trailers it looks like
a straightforward
carnage is breaking now we gotta stop
carnage it's carnage versus venom that's
exactly what it looked like right when
you were watching the movie
and or when watching the trailers and
then you watch the movie and it feels
like that's one-third and two-thirds of
the movie are mainly about venom and
eddie not getting along and going
through like some comedy breakup film
right so that that actually threw me a
little bit for a loop and i didn't find
it as so i found myself actually less
interested in the carnage stuff
and more interested in what the movie
really seemed to provide more of its
inventiveness around
or the creativity which was around the
venom and eddie relationship that being
said
when the question was indeed presented
to me of what would i have changed my
mind did start going
i i would change it's a weird movie to
me because on the one hand i very much
i've seen it twice now and i enjoyed it
both times more the second time but
there is still a lot i would change
about it and it's one of those movies
where i think like
on a more objective tilt i'm like this
is kind of a c plus movie but on an
enjoyability tip it's like a b plus a
minus movie yeah um and yeah it's odd
because i don't i didn't expect the odd
couple movie either and yet i think
that's like the stuff that works the
best and when the movie finally hits the
point where eddie and venom break up uh
then it
hits much more of a stride than i think
it had up until that point like it's
weird because there's so many competing
elements that i think it's hard not to
rewrite this movie in your head a little
bit because you can see the beginning
threads of so many things that if you
took them a little further could have
been very rich and interesting and all
together they are like a fun jumble but
there is uh
it's an unruly movie in a way that's
funny to me because in some ways i'm
like it kind of matches who these
characters are you know it's got a lot
of weird tendrils shooting off of it
like a symbiote might but at the same
time as a complete movie i can
absolutely see why every opinion has
been different yeah you know well i
think if you went on opening weekend the
sensationalism of the crowd seemed very
apparent where you could hear the
uproarious crowds
uh we didn't watch it with a crowd of
that caliber where it had such a you
know like such a volume of just
enthusiasm or surrounded by us of people
who were extremely high so it was
actually easy to just take the filament
for what it is and and judge it off of
that i kind of wanted
because i'm seeing even just in this
live stream alone we're as we're talking
i'm also reading everyone's opinions
that are coming in right now and
i i personally think that i put out a
tweet that said i think there's like 15
deleted scenes that were either deleted
or not shot for the movie and that could
be just in the fact of letting like some
extra dialogue let this scene breathe
let this moment breathe i felt like this
movie just did not want to breathe at
all
and let things percolate let things
really build because i honestly didn't
feel any stakes like while i was
entertained i never felt stakes or
any emotional concern or any intensity i
was just kind of watching stuff happen
on screen and it was really loud you
know yeah it's very like a cacophony
yeah so i while i and and while i
ultimately walked out going no i still
had fun
i couldn't help but also feel a bit
disappointed in how it ultimately came
across which was um
i thought what would have made the
carnage storyline specifically better
where like i said normally i don't like
to come on and just start rewriting a
movie however that someone did present
it to me and i was like actually yeah i
think i would have wanted this more
especially based off what the trailers
were giving us to me the trailers felt
more focused than the movie
um where i would have wanted like
because you have this setup at the very
top
where or cletus cassidy is unusually
obsessed with eddie brock right and he
it's like people are obsessed with
serial killers but weirdly the serial
killer's obsessed with this reporter who
he seems to know an unusual amount about
this guy's life so he's really obsessed
with him
and then when he gets the carnage uh
symbiote
i thought like what they could have done
to perhaps make this more emotionally
engaging would be you have
cletus this guy who's obviously like yes
he's a serial killer but he's obviously
a character who has a desperate need for
connection and he's rejected by eddie
brock but carnage can be the thing that
accepts him and makes him feel whole and
fulfilled and so i thought maybe they
could have done some type of plot line
where now that he realizes like eddie is
venom and like now he's just like eddie
to in his own mind because he has
carnage he can try to meet up with venom
and eddie but then venom uh and eddie
reject him because like no you're crazy
you're a psychopath yeah you're not one
of us yeah so because what didn't make
sense to me was like in the comics it
made sense why carnage hates venom
because
based off the origin that takes place in
the comic where eddie and cletus are
shacked up together in prison cletus
wants to kill eddie symbiote attaches
itself at least from the maximum
carter's run symbiote attaches itself
uh reattaches itself back to eddie and
then
basically yeah when he becomes carnage
uh cletus
venom and eddie stop him so basically he
cletus is not able to have the freedom
and live the life he wants to live and
so that's why they were like they they
cletus and carnage both reject eddie and
venom so at least there's a personal
motive there i cannot understand in the
movie
why does carnage like i hate father i
want him to like i didn't i didn't get
that so i thought they could have had
that rejection in there and then they
could have done something more
interesting with carnage and cletus
where when they do finally get shriek
like now we are complete and what could
start to tear them apart carnage and
clear like they are symbiotic because
they're more it's like he's more carne's
more infused into
cletus's blood than venom is with eddie
so they are like the true symbiosis
and then when they have shriek that's
when [ __ ] could start to go wrong
because shriek's powers
are a threat to carnage so then carnage
and cletus are at like odds with each
other because they don't know what to do
because cletus wants shriek but khan
doesn't want her you know so i thought
like they could have done a better build
in emotional engagement and character
development because it didn't feel like
all that kind of just felt russian
perfunctory and just very much like
what's the bare minimum we got to do to
get to the finale yeah
it's weird that's how it felt because
all that stuff is there like all this
all the ingredients to make these
interesting character plot lines are in
the movie and that's i think the most
kind of upsetting thing because as it
stands in the final theatrical cut you
know it's like okay why does cletus want
that thing he says the end about like
all he wanted was for you to be my
friend and i'm like well why wh what
about any of of your relationship to
each other suggest that or just yeah i
don't know expound upon it let me know
because like i thought it was really
interesting the way that they have that
conflict with shriek at the end and the
way that you know it at least drives a
wedge between cletus and carnage but at
the same time
you know that character uh of shriek is
pretty underutilized francis barrison
and uh you know even like i was
they set me up for a bunch of stuff and
i feel like you cast woody harrelson in
this and you already immediately have
people thinking natural born killers
because of the you know setup of this
movie and i feel like they really could
have leaned into that more and really
built upon their relationship because i
feel like so much of this movie and it
does to me both times feel like it got
really cut down and there are things
that are smoothed over with like here's
a fade here's a quick like cut to this
person saying a really succinct line or
whatever but you know if you had really
gone in and had those character
relationships open up and you could have
it's like you could have even rid the
pg-13 without uh you know going into
gore carnage but going into contextual
darkness you know you could have had
just the history of cletus and francis
you know to kind of fill this up and
their tortured love and then yeah by the
end ultimately cletus is on this amazing
power trip but what's the one thing
that's gonna tear him apart from his
perfect symbiosis it's you know the love
of his life who's also the antithesis to
what this creature is like it's all
there and yet it's not because it feels
like they cut everything down to be just
the plot b well yeah they didn't they
didn't leave any of the nuance
in there which is what elevates
everything yeah cause like when even
when uh when shriek is having changes of
heart or is like at odds with carnage
you're like okay where is this coming
from why do you care about anne you know
yeah you see like there's someone in the
chat here oh i just missed it um
someone in the chat just sorry there
were some chimney comps just came in and
now we can't reload it um just said
that
carnage the reason why he uh he hates
venom his father is because cletus hated
his father and i transferred over to him
i'm like i think you're just filling
that in
that's not in the movie yeah
that's not in here it's a decent it's a
decent head cannon like i'll give it to
you but but yeah it's like half the
other people honestly think that yeah
it's like it's also not explained how
carter's able to hack the internet the
way he did
which is my favorite part
i i don't yeah i mean there's there's
definitely things about it that
do work um
for me it's just it's really just what's
missing for me are better fleshed out
details that's that's about it it's just
exploring more of that
technically i'm just like oh if you just
layered this a little bit more because
that's all i was kind of doing when i
was saying here's what i would have done
i'm just really kind of adding on to
what's already there
uh just making it a little bit more
trying to make it more nuanced it's like
one thing that was also kind of missing
for me as a fan of venom is
as much as i love tom hardy and i love
venom in this and as much as i think
they are the best parts in both the
first movie and this movie they're my
absolute favorite parts i
also it one beat that is really missing
for me in this movie is i never really
got and i'm curious enough you guys felt
this way
i never really got
the sense
that
that eddie needed venom you know what i
mean like eddie like venom it's real
they really do a good job on
establishing
whether you like the execution or not
they at least really flesh that out here
that why venom is so attached to eddie
and in this movie i it still by the end
felt like
eddie's kind of cursed with venom but he
doesn't really have a desire to be with
venom and as uh and not that's that's
that is a missing beat for me here that
i never really got the sense of like you
know when eddie and what they could what
i'm saying is like i don't know exactly
what they could have done but when eddie
and venom are broken up and they are
separated
i thought they could have given time to
eddie to show him without his the
symbiote in him and to really showcase
what like the
why the breakup on his side of why he
needs venom like personally emotionally
yeah not just [ __ ] carnage
yeah
that was a missing beat for me
um but you know you keep going back to
the same thing was like as much as all
this is missing
it's like when i take the film as what
it is
like i said it's it is something that is
like
it's fun
at the same time i'm like oh but there's
such a better movie here so
uh yeah okay we gotta we got a few super
chats that we're gonna just go to really
quick yeah but reading a lot of these
comments here it does seem like i feel
like a lot of us are actually more on
the same page
which is like reading every comment
that's been coming in has been yeah it's
entertaining it's fun but you know it's
uh
it could have been better yeah
it could have been better
i love that the the the it seems like
the consistent uh stripe of the venom
movies right now is like you know there
it's a step in the right direction
hopefully next time they'll now yeah
yeah yeah
hopefully we will talk about the mid
credit the mid credit scene in just a
bit
um but yeah can you refresh the chat
here too yeah you just scroll down i'm
trying to read to the actual chat too
venom ate his son that's one way to look
at him and almost did die like one it
did feel like in reference to amazing
spider-man 2 for sure absolutely
all right toxin setup
streamlabs will be read out loud too
yeah yeah all righty so i prefer
streamlabs honestly it's actually much
easier to work with this so yeah yeah
but uh always appreciate any and all of
you guys
sing says i don't like you greg thanks
for being here cardiki
way to waste your life yeah
without wasted even more
i don't like it with this you are being
here so i'm here so i'm going to just
make make
life difficult for me from here on out
and we'll all sabotage myself
we will only read insults in the form of
super chats from now on
uh the car yeah see how cars are able to
hack to enter in the comics okay
explain it in the movie stuff should it
just work within the context of the
movie well yeah and the fact that they
give him his own little red browser that
just gets right to the only to the
information that's exactly pertinent
yeah it's a little silly
all right uh willie aye
thank you for the little uh super
sticker here it's adorable little
running goal man thank you buddy yeah
and robo ian what does that say you got
a little fist bump going on in there
with uh with words on the knucks that
are so small right now i can't read them
but still thank you uh robo ian turbo
striker what are your thoughts thank you
and shouts out to canada uh here we go
good canadian boy
turbo striker what are your thoughts
about venom not getting an mcu setup
version like spider-man iron man and the
others also love your vids
i appreciate everyone stepping in in
this live stream chat saying like
uh i like you greg i love you greg hey
[ __ ] that one guy all right he's a loser
forget him you are a loser
you are a loser
um
turbo striker what are your thoughts
about venom okay well here's the thing
about uh venom not getting mc7 version
like spider-man and the others i would
say i appreciate you uh contributing
here what i would say
is i'm actually you know a little bit
concerned
i'm gonna try to spread out this talk
because i know this is gonna be a big
part of the discussion as we proceed
what what i'm what i really want like
here's what i want for the venom and
spider-man to finally cross over of
course when i'm going to get the white
spider logo i want to get the whips yes
i want that to finally be brought to
life
what i'm a little apprehensive about is
they're not going to deliver on a good
rivalry movie and i'll kind of go into
that a little bit later more as to why
um but with not having this mcu set up
i'm i'm kind of like
okay are you gonna hop straight too
because that movie ended right on the
lethal protector note
so is in that lethal protector umbrella
are is are they gonna be viewing
spider-man as this threat they gotta
stop so they're to immediately kind of
be like a bvs situation like we don't
agree
yeah and then we're going to have a
common enemy at the end they'll be so
they're going to do that in one movie
or are they going to um
yeah sorry we're going to say no i was
going to agree with you i could see them
that seems like the most sensible
thing to do with what they have right
now if the idea is to get spider-man and
venom facing off asap is like you have
them be at odds over something probably
the situation that is just being
revealed about spider-man's a menace and
he killed mysterio and then you know
have it be that oh by the end eddie
finally sees the truth and then they can
team up because i'm like
really quick here's the thing is like
why would
at the end of that movie it looks like
venom has been thrusted into the mcu
universe yes wouldn't that be the main
thing that guy has to deal with
before dealing anything with spider-man
and like why would their concern
immediately goat maybe there's a reason
that will feel well justified
but i'm a little bit concerned about the
execution of this upcoming movie because
rumor has it at least the main thing
speculate is that it's not venom in a
spider-man movie it's spider-man in a
venom movie so
i'm a little bit concerned that after
dealing with venomverse and riot and
then ultimately feeling disappointed by
venomverse and carnage like the story of
that i'm not talking about fight scenes
like the story of that
i am going
let me
i love how this guy just said you're
biased as [ __ ] when i'm like we've just
spent like 20 minutes criticizing the
movie yeah
come on
come on
uh uh you were talking about how it
looks like it's gonna be more of a venom
uh spider-man in a venom movie versus
venom in a spider-man movie and how
they're going to ultimately get them at
odds with each other i feel like you
need to do
i'm still kind of it's weird it's as
much as i've been one of the people who
has been championing for venom versus
spider-man if you are throwing venom
into the spider-man movie
or venom into the mcu i am also going
well maybe we need to do one more movie
that's not exactly venom versus
spider-man because you're throwing venom
into a completely new reality where he's
surrounded by superheroes and like the
whole world is different and they didn't
have a whole blip experience like you're
throwing eddie brock into like a brand
new world now you know well and that's
the big question to me is that how
now on this part of the timeline could
you get venom into a villainous and
eddie into a villainous position because
you know i mean it seems like tom hardy
and venna and eddie brock this eddie
brock are very much hero protagonist
good guy types so i don't really i can't
really fathom in this iteration unless
they do a a variant of some kind where
you could have them full-on rivals or
enemies or or you know the classic
depiction of venom versus spider-man you
know
you know okay look one thing i want to
acknowledge too is i've seen some people
come in this live stream and talk about
how they don't have a release in their
country yet yeah which is
like a lot of people have already done
their spoiler talks and their breakdowns
and everything like that you guys get
james bond first
like we're we're mainly a us-based
channel at the end of the day um like 90
of our demographic because you more than
90
i do think it's really [ __ ] weird how
they they've separated the release dates
on them so much yeah when i'm like you
have a post-credits scene on this
caliber yeah this is not the same as
like separating bond
all right yeah like this is like a
game-changing post-credit scene yeah and
you're not like you're spread it out so
much you just expect people not to talk
about it yeah so weird yeah especially
for a movie with like that's a tentpole
and yeah that ties into the other
biggest movie of the freaking year
yeah
it is it is a little mind-boggling
joseph curtis all right
i think this movie was way too silly do
you agree or disagree did you think the
comedy beats were well balanced
it was i was uh
i would say more
often than not i actually found it funny
some jokes were a little bit
sometimes it was like too childish for
me
and then other times it really worked
for me yeah
like sometimes i was like we don't need
comedy right now at this moment yeah but
but sometimes that that moments where it
felt like the comedy was not needed
still kind of worked for me yeah like
when carnage is going
father no not you father
why is it so stupid but i like it
yeah
and yet i think it's kind of funny yeah
but i even like the bit even when venom
is going uh like he goes oh [ __ ] you
know that's a red one it's a red one and
we'll understand let's just go yeah we
never liked her anyway
so some people will look at that and i
feel it i'm like when i say conflicted
i'm conflicted because
when i'm looking at venom in the comics
venom wouldn't be that way he would he
would venom hates carnage yeah he hates
him like he must destroy him you know
venom hates him and it but in the movie
for the venom that they have created for
the film if i'm not drawing comic
comparisons and i'm just looking at the
film that is in tune with the childish
behavior of venom in this movie so to me
that comedy scene actually worked um but
i also what i always say is like if you
don't like that i completely get it uh
there were times where i thought like
some beats were going on a little too
long like the whole club scene was just
so weird and it felt a little too drawn
out you know yeah but um
at the end of the day i would say more
often than not there were some there
were some comedy things where i was like
okay we don't need non-stop comedy but
more often than not i would say i
actually laughed sometimes i was
laughing when i don't think i was
supposed to be laughing sometimes i was
like what the [ __ ] this is moving so
fast what the hell's going on somebody
in the live chat just said too much
comedy but most of the jokes hit yeah
and i was like yeah i kind of that's
about it that's about it yeah yeah yeah
knock knock the devil hey michael
welcome to the chat yeah now what i want
to know is what everyone thought of the
new eminem song
did people like it
you know people were disappointed eminem
did not take the opportunity to rhyme
carnage with orange carnage
it's red and orange all carnage orange
eminem has his ways of rhyming i got
another song
[ __ ] for the strong-willed
all right pandemic jones love ya buddy
shouts out the one thing that confused
me was that they showed venom getting
transported to the mcu when peter
parker's identity got revealed which
makes it seem like doctor strange's
spell and peter's tampering was not the
cause
oh it's an interesting correlation so
what you're saying is because a lot of
people have kind of questioned that
whole thing with vetom saying i'm going
to show you it was like eight billion or
eight million something like that yeah
i'm gonna show you like eight billion
something five mind of eight billion
multiple universes blah blah blah yeah
it's just something like that that he
gets transported into venom like that
wasn't my doing yeah so that immediately
makes you go is that the whole doctor
strange thing
but you're saying that because of the
timing of that that you don't think it's
actually dr strange who's who did that
okay that's a fair
that's a fair theory to have okay i kind
of just chalked it up to coincidence
yeah i think that's an interesting
question because people have been asking
like well you know even though venom
says that wasn't me like was it him as a
result of opening up that wealth of
knowledge to eddie is it wanda is it
doctor strange is it who is it who is it
why is it sylvie which to me right now
almost feels like the most likely
culprit because that's removed from
everybody so you don't have to worry
about doctor strange casting a spell at
the wrong time it's funny i i think that
we keep forgetting about a lot of people
are not factoring in the events of what
happened at the end of loki anymore yeah
i know everyone's just going is this one
street
and maybe most likely because you know
like it seems like the shows are there
to support and elevate the movies versus
the other way around sometimes
so maybe but i'm like that that whole
thing that happens at the end of loki
has to be a major effect on what's
happening to the movies right well and
to me
it feels almost like that would be the
most likely because in loki they're like
yeah that's crashing multiverses
together and so to me it makes a lot
more sense like yeah the sony's offshoot
world could come in because of that more
so to me than like doctor strange
casting the spell that seems like it's
supposed to apply to one universe you
know yeah uh but yeah convenience stumps
when it makes sense to this movie well
portrait acts regarding what we're
saying is saying nah it messes with
space and time so strange did it like
gwen went back and taught a bit in time
for spider-verse that's true we might
have to actually
revisit spider-verse yeah to see how
some of the because they might be taking
rules from there and applying it here
which would make more sense
i just hope this doesn't become
confusing
it's already like which rules are we
exactly applying here but that's a good
point that is a good point i appreciate
that absolutely somebody see but
spider-man hasn't talked to doctor
strange when venomous lando is saying
that so how can it possibly be him yeah
that's what i mean it's like space and
time works weird it's sure it sure looks
like he gets brought back at the moment
that uh jay jonah jameson's revealing
peter so you guys remember this moment
when we say we didn't we don't look at
the regular livestream
i just love too that the shot they got
of peter is such an awkward like he's
just standing looking around yeah
like where did you get this footage
people are up
i feel this movie was yeah
but that mid credit scene was fire hey
thanks it's a short life i really
appreciate that comment i feel like
that's uh i feel like that's what some
people's predictions about the entire
movie were gonna be like the movie
itself whatever i feel like we've even
talked about this like a bunch of times
but everyone will talk about the post
credits well the post-credits scene
scene i kind of felt like they were in a
rush to get to the final fight and the
post-credits scene i know when
weirdly my main takeaway was not
actually the post-credits scene um which
might be a bit odd considering the
amount of coverage we do on the future
of the mcu you know but that wasn't my
takeaway i was really it's like to me it
wasn't my takeaway because it was like
okay it's finally happening you know
okay they're finally doing it but
admittedly i was left with a bit of
concern because of the fact that carnage
and oh yeah do you want to pull that up
we do have street lamps um
yeah thank you sarah we do have
we i had the concern because of what
happens with this with the venom movies
that we've gotten that i'm like i don't
feel like they've ultimately really
delivered on
good versus movies you know yeah and it
i did have the question that i think a
lot of people are having which is
okay
maybe somewhere in the the cosmos of the
8 billion
universe whatever the hell venom says at
the end in the post-credits scene
somehow that links to like
venom doesn't like a variant or a past
experience with a different spider-man
yeah right okay maybe that's to explain
i don't know why eddie brock this like
45 year old reporter who would hate this
teenager
when he has to deal already with this
whole new world yeah you know of
superheroes and whatever like this
craziness that his world does not
inhabit doesn't have chitari doesn't
have the age of ultron doesn't have dan
who doesn't have any of that he's got a
whole lot more but he's going to be like
[ __ ] that spiderman
i don't know why he's gonna deal with
that yeah not to mention that peter
isn't working in journalism or
photography yet yeah yeah so no personal
reason for eddie himself to get involved
with a rivalry i don't so i i don't know
what it would be there that when i'm
like it seems like they have to do a lot
to make this fluid
they have to do a reimagining and i'm
not i'm always going to give them a
chance i'm never going to go it's going
to suck or or it'll for sure be great
i'm always going to give it a chance but
i do have concerns that they're not
going to pull it off well when i'm
thinking
they botched it with spider-man versus
venom and spider-man 3
[Music]
as much as that movie has grown in
appreciation over time i don't feel like
the appreciation has grown because of
the venom qualities in that movie maybe
the black symbiote suit which is
something i'm like that's another thing
i really want them to do right is peter
gained the black symbiote suit
so
yeah i'm i am i am apprehensive i'm
cautiously optimistic about it and i'm
not like everyone else with this is like
the [ __ ] credits because for me i'm
like
i'm weirdly left with some cautious
optimism yeah yeah well i got it if they
just have it be that peter starts dating
anne perfect inroad for right yeah why
not yeah and eddie hate them and there
you go yeah
but yeah that's that's a that's a very
good uh
call there can we uh refresh the chat as
the chat right here yeah
but that's a good i like that that was
the one theory that came to my mind is
like maybe somehow venom remembers his
tobey maguire experience this is some
kind but at the same time i'm like you
mean to tell me like
every
okay
i love what they're doing at least say
it with spider-man no way home the
concept of it yes of you're getting the
three spider-man and these villains and
they're all being mashed into one movie
but if then the venom is not developed
from a personal antagonistic
relationship with tom holland spider-man
yeah that doesn't really trap then i'm
like so is every one of these great
villains gonna be from a different
spider-man villain and not from our tom
holland because that's what i think we
need i think we deserve that we need
some thomas calendars
all right glad they did so am i sarah
williamson i'm glad they sell that
lawsuit she was paid fair and square
that scarlett oh hey eleven clubs and
then the other and then they and then
they announced black widow coming
available everywhere on disney plus
oh awesome perfect
covering up those tracks all right
tongue punch fart box thank you for
jumping into the stream labs donations
hi guys not sure if i liked the movie or
not i saw maybe half and fell asleep i
saw up to where carnage broke out of
jail i think i ended up waking up right
as the credits started rolling i can't
rate it until i see it again
i'm surprised uh
i'm surprised
the tongue punch fell asleep that uh
people are falling asleep during this
movie because it's just so chaotic that
maybe you just zone out and get used to
the noise you know i've seen movies like
that where you're like if i was if i was
properly hooked into this it would be
probably fun and bombastic however if
i'm not this is gonna be just like a
smear of lights and loud noises and i
probably won't be able to latch into
yeah and it'll sound like gibberish so
maybe that's what tongue punch had
because yeah if you're not into it i
could see this being a very excruciating
movie for you
look guys it makes me uncomfortable to
be the guy to come on the internet and
express a lot of apprehension for the
post-credits scene after everything i'm
very excited for and knowing that the
main
talk this is the spider-man channel you
can't just do that the main yeah the
main talk on uh
you know the zeitgeist of youtube is how
amazing this post-credits scene is and
everything like that the thing is i'm
under the impression this is going to be
more of a sony film and not an mcu film
yes but i'm probably wrong we don't know
we don't know we don't know for sure a
lot of people have sold themselves that
it's either or but we don't know for
sure if it's mainly mcu marvel i i feel
like kevin feige is going to make sure
that even if it is mainly a sony film
he's going to want to make sure he's
really involved to make sure this goes
well yeah yeah even though a lot of his
notes were rejected for amazing
spider-man
really well is that true yeah those
leaked emails showed it uh
i think so i think it's worse oh man
i love doran what's up flev hi guys
sadly i can't watch the stream because i
couldn't see the movie as you know but
by next week things should be calm down
here and i shall be able to see it then
will you let us know what you think
buddy
team waiting i don't want to kick you
out of the chat but uh the squid game
reactions will be up don't worry it's
coming flev continues
also i wanted to say
that i liked that you gave me a shout
out in a venom spoiler video knowing i
didn't see the movie if that was the
intention if that was intentional i can
appreciate the irony it wasn't inten if
it wasn't intentional it's still funny
no no no that was intentional
full credit for that
hey i saw many saying to new work uh
over the weekend how was it was it great
and i also saw midnight monologues
what is that uh it's mike flanagan's new
show
oh yes midnight monologues i have heard
tell i have heard tell midnight
monologues i haven't seen all of it
all those five page monologues every
episode that's all i know about the show
every time there's about to be it's like
oh [ __ ] we got another monologue coming
in all i know about this show is it's
gonna make you think about religion and
monologues baby monologue i call it
i'm excited to see it literally like the
fifth episode some character does go did
i tell you why i became this i'm like
here we go
is it good
it's fantastic all right i've never i
had never seen a trailer read a plot
description you nothing and uh just i'm
almost done with it anyways the poster
it's [ __ ] it's great it's great go in
knowing nothing and be patient copy that
very patient but once you start
understanding what they're doing it's
[ __ ] great um
sean mclaughlin my favorite moment of
yours is me calling you humble one
stream and greg calling me a big dick in
the next stream in response just to
prove he's not humble i love this
channel man welcome your sack of [ __ ]
thanks sean
appreciate it
appreciate it
did you guys see many say uh many things
in new work i'm curious to know what
people think about it
and do you want to see him team up with
venom tony soprano yeah
as weird as i love uh ooh spider-man's
thomas madden in the chats and
spider-man's four title is spider-man
let there be venom that would be a
pretty bomb title if they gave
spider-man and venom their whole own
movie together like
as much as i'm apprehensive and as much
as it isn't reminiscent right now of the
original comic book origin and there's a
lot about spider-man at the moment that
isn't
uh you know they could still just build
something new
um
by the way i want to thank my sister for
making the thumbnail for us yeah i had a
vision
and then i said
throw us in there gave some notes i gave
my direction it was like blow up venom
and uh we're gonna put john right here
for some tv have a coming in yeah
maybe this dimension
perfect
look like we're in the post credits
someone said venom because people are
talking about the box office in this
live stream right now someone said venom
might be the first
movie in the pandemic to break a billion
i don't think so
i would be very surprised i would think
it'd be chunky if anybody i feel like
everyone should watch the post-credits
scene online oh that too cause like the
amount of leaks there have been and the
amount of leaks that haven't been taken
down is venom gonna be
uh a release in china is it released in
china i don't know chongqi isn't i don't
know
last i heard it was under it was still
like a question mark but that's uh that
could be changed now
captain jay uh oh by the way who was the
last person i'm so sorry uh thank you
thank you
sean mccoy sean mclaughlin did you feel
the movie was too short or rushed do you
think venom can you make that like wider
why is it like coming in at this like
downward
stacked
that's how they blow don't change it
john we don't want you to panic
did you feel the movie was too short or
rushed do you think venom gonna be in no
way home or they will be the credit
scene how many times are you gonna see
venom again i love your videos i'm gonna
make the most i can out of this
streamlabs
who was too short rushed i did feel it
was both too short and rushed
ultimately still enjoyed it but
definitely
do you think venom gonna be in no way
home or there will be the credit scene
i think venom will probably be in the
post-credits scene or the mid-credit
scene mcu films tend to have two
mid-credit and post-credit and i feel
like he'll be in one of the other that
makes it which would be cool yeah how
many he gets transformed into a hotel
room and sees venom on the tv yeah that
guy yeah
who is he how many times are you gonna
go see venom again
let's wait uh
love your videos thank you captain jay
appreciate it yeah
thanks buddy
uh brandon's currently tracking for 800
million you say
china will give a boost because they
love the first movie okay oh yeah
yeah for sure
i mean i i was already surprised by just
how well this seems to be doing out the
gate so can you highlight that please
dasha's always watching
this movie was like watching a reaction
video where they cut enough of the movie
to where you kind of know what's
happening but they didn't leave enough
with the movie to get copyrighted
i've been kind of
seen
absolutely feelings i
but i did have fun watching it love your
videos that is the overall vibe
yeah
my goodness cats you guys can't hear
this we got a cat going crazy right now
i think sherlock needs medicated food
sherlock is nice there's olivia in the
chat
oh really yes
did she message me
she messaged the the entirety of the
real rejects fan base okay
dude thanks for letting us know olivia
deshay is always watching oh yeah i know
i i think you're 100 right the movie's
definitely rushed yeah
there's no there's no point in uh
there's no way i don't think anyone
could really
dispute that and if you try to i'm just
not going to agree that early if you
don't feel that then [ __ ] that i wish i
felt that way that early moment where
eddie's in the hallway uh and this is
like the first time that struck me but
like when he's in the hallway with uh
with uh steven graham who's name i'm now
mulligan and then he has that whole
thing in the bathroom and then he comes
back out that is the most weirdly edited
scene where you can tell like they just
chose a moment to cut the bathroom bit
to get back to the other scene this
whole scene probably was like 10 minutes
later in the original cut of this film
like yeah it's it's a strange one for a
movie as rushed as it is i thought
carnage broke out surprisingly late i
know it's so weird
i keep wondering what the original
structure of the movie was and part of
me kept wishing like maybe there is on
the cutting room floor somewhere like
some scenes where venom or where eddie
and cletus actually had those like
one-on-one talks i was like that could
have been interesting
but that's what i mean they could have
really milked that like literally let
the relationship build kind of like a
clarice yeah and hannibal thing yeah
they seem like they set themselves
yeah that's the thing is there's so much
there's so much um potential there's
opportunity for sure they set themselves
up for for silence of the natural born
killers and then used neither
i would like circus if they do
eventually like down the road reboot
planet of the apes it would be cool for
him to shoot that that would be cool
make it a fast-paced 90-minute comedy
yeah then a remake of the hobbit where
he directs it too
venom uh crown venom recognized
spider-man when he said that guy
uh exactly
it suited up immediately so i think
since the symbiotes have history that's
where the feud
will stem from yeah you see that's the
thing though is like okay i i get that
but it seems like a lot based off the
trailers for no way home we don't
exactly know how the movies are gonna
ultimately progress right but it seems
like
unless the result just mainly footage
manipulation and doc ox hello peter is
directed at toby maguire maybe
at the end of the day it seems like
villains from these other spider-man
movies who have a history with a
different spider-man
are going after tom holland still you
know even if they're going after toby
maguire and andrew garfield they're
still
lumping in tom holland into that yeah so
going into tom holland
and so i want i just want something more
personal
with venom with tom hardy and tom
holland i want a personal rivalry
between them it has to feel personal not
only does
this have to be mainly peter's problem
this also has to be venom's uh uh lust
yeah yeah yeah it's like having having
some kind of hive mind memory of tobey
mcguire like answers the logistical but
it doesn't do anything for the actual
investment in their conflict yeah you
know beyond just everybody wanting to
see it come to life
all right we're at the top of the soup
of the stream let's go back to the
supers
but first let's shout out some people in
the live chat
they don't uh rudster says people
sometimes forget they also try to make
these movies as accurate to the comics
which they've been doing extremely well
with i personally enjoy and no hate that
anyone said that to anyone who didn't
like it
i feel like it's i'm fascinated i feel
like there's a lot that's very different
what people think of this take because
it seems like they do reference the
comics and they do borrow
plot line details but then deviate
heavily across all these movies i never
i haven't come across the comic that has
and maybe there is a comic out there and
if you guys know please tell me in the
chat i have to me my understanding the
history with shriek and carnage is not
what's in here where shriek shriek meets
carnage when carnage is breaking out
um
and then she has like uh she's she's
like it's like 80s rock band group
person that groupie personality and she
is a malevolent threat and i really do
think i wish that i was kind of bummed
when they killed off carnage because i'm
like oh man what about the maximum
carnage storyline we're like the whole
[ __ ] city's going literally at
maximum carnage it's not just spider-man
and venom having to handle [ __ ]
everybody
you're like get every hero anybody who's
not on vacation
bring them in throw them in here
so yeah i really want um i i i think
they could have and shriek too her
powers are not just like
she's able to [ __ ] with people's minds
yeah that's a big part of her power set
wasn't and we didn't explore that either
and i felt like that was like oh man
why'd you call up both these there's so
much such a cooler movie here to do well
isn't that a crucial aspect of the
resolve in maximum carnage is that like
her her telekinetic ability or
telepathic abilities factor in
yes yeah that's what's making that's
what's aiding in the city uh where
everyone in new york is kind of going
crazy and bringing out the worst in them
which brings out a conflict it's a it's
a real like insidious
um chapter two dreadfilled story uh it
was real menacing and they don't have it
yeah hola andrea andy carnage might not
be completely dead venom has eaten
carnage before
he's a hungry boy
b gill studios thank you for this
charming sticker of this like little
thanks ruster groovy cow guy i think if
i'm reading that correctly stevo gaming
th i feel like that's awesome was
supposed to die but they cut it out for
some reason and it undercuts the stakes
they seem to be setting up
i don't know
i never got that said she was gonna talk
they did i'd be like oh
michelle williams probably asked for
that that's what i wanted that's what i
would have thought i don't wanna come
back it was definitively
[Laughter]
yeah i never thought you would die no
fact when she got kidnapped you know
see i felt like there's always a threat
to make things more personal
even with the priest i was thinking what
if this was like a guy from his
orphanage like one of the priests who
came in here and he like forced him into
this position to marry them yeah you
know like you kept us apart yeah yeah
yeah all of this
all of this could have been so much more
personal and yeah and it's like all
things that wouldn't make it too harsh
or too well i mean harsher but not too
like r-rated or anything like that you
know some people want like gore and [ __ ]
and i'm like yeah i want that too but
we're not gonna get it so there's other
ways of delivering remember how like
unsettling the dark knight was the first
time you watch it just feels like it's
just like so dark yeah
and that's all you need it's mainly
emotion and tone and a feeling not
really
i don't think it needs to be heavily
reliant on even though i'm like well i
feel like i'll take the door ultimately
properly to do carnage you need the core
you know especially for someone as
vicious as him
all right creative been watching for
years love you buddy i legit took notes
on a doc giving pros and cons and
overall thoughts while watching so one
hundred percent
six out of ten movie just hope i would
love to see that document
yeah please what's on the pros what's on
the cons and how many things are on both
lists just okay
i did the math
i tallied it up percentage-wise
60
scientifically speaking this movie is
just okay objectively i ran the numbers
i think it would be a bold move man of
action if they did madam chaction in the
chat is asking if they would do an
r-rated i don't think they will but i
think it would be a bold move if they
started doing that for some of their
films because they just don't what if
that was the case with venom let there
be carnage is the only reason the
theatrical cut is so choppy is they cut
all the r-rated stuff out so everything
else in the movie was just like way
explicit yeah
or they could just get quarter crew to
do some blood add-ons yeah they made
venom rated it's at least in the first
venom movie you see venom bite one guy's
head off yeah yeah he bites
half carnage half cletus so it's not
like as vicious as it might it's not as
violent i think they get like one head
bite but that was a good use of the
f-bomb you see it was that was a solid
use of the fbi yeah not gonna lie you
see
you see a couple of head-eating moments
but it's like there's a headless body on
the ground yeah i'm off-screen
mysteryman723
i personally don't think the strength of
the cletus and carnage bond was shown
enough but it was shown a bit i swear
there's a better movie in here somewhere
and that's exactly what i was talking
about is like in order for us what i was
saying at the top of this stream was how
i think they could have developed that a
lot where cletus finally finds the
connection he's been yearning for yeah
and then it gets
threatened when carnage finds shriek in
her power set to be a threat to them and
their symbiosis like that that'd be like
the ultimate wedge between them i
thought that would have been such a cool
thing yeah that would have made them way
more personal for them and kind of make
it like a tragedy
yeah absolutely like
there's so many weird things about
carnage across the movie and the other
thing that made me wonder is you know in
the comics you have this idea that okay
like it fuses with his blood and there's
a symbiosis on a whole other level that
eddie brock doesn't necessarily engage
with venom on but in this movie it's
because of eddie's blood which appears
to have already mutated so i'm like why
does carnage get all crazy like is it
still involved with cletus's blood and
they just never talk about that or why
is carnage so much crazier if he's based
off of eddie brock and eddie brock is
just kind of venom and venom's like no
not the red guy can't do the red guy you
know you know it'll be a bold move
from reading some comments here in the
chat right now you want to be bold
what's that
if they let sam raimi do venom three
and then give him a spiderman
give him a redo yeah how cool would that
be because it seems like they're trying
to capture especially with this it seems
like they're trying to do
some type of
like comedy horror adjacent thingy yeah
which is what sam raimi excels in
so if he's able to do like a venom movie
that does that
that has that wacky gonzo quality to it
but also like horror and exciting and
weird comedy that's because he knows how
to mesh the the weird weird comedy with
horror really well i'm like yeah he'd
actually do a pretty great venom oh yeah
standalone movie oh yeah dude yeah plus
think of how many crazy lobster tank
scenes we'll get then
as it's treble just said in the chat
i think sam raimi does not like venom
yeah he's made that's pretty clear
i would like the movie but i know he has
no interest in the character i want him
to suffer through making this movie for
my own enjoyment
robo dance
do you think since new kangs are moving
into the mcu timeline he is the one
causing characters moving into different
timelines and merging the timelines
could be yeah i do think so um i do i
mean
we don't know ever the theories seem to
be going to what happens in the trailer
and doctor strange
and what's going on with king at the end
of
uh the loki finale so we don't know but
i don't know i want them to make it more
about the kang thing since that seems to
be the
the real big thing like i already forgot
about not just some spell that went
wrong with doctor strange yeah cause
then i'm like way to go d strange you
made everything worse
i thought we had problems during loki
it's like if he's the it seems like to
me d strange will probably be the one
replacing the head
like how iron man was essentially the
head of the mcu yeah it would make some
sense and now it seems like that's going
to be doctor strange especially where
they're thematically and genre exploring
yeah he is the most well versed in the
places we're headed yeah so i i feel
like that's what we're doing doctor
strange so i find it fascinating how a
lot of the way the mcu progresses is
based off of consequential choices
from
the uh you get a lot of common i don't
know why that's
from consequential choices
of our of our head honchos yeah it's
fascinating
i know some people really don't want
venom in the mcu who have this version
of venom specifically yeah i get it
all right let's move on yeah faizan khan
do you think cletus and carnage should
have died no and no one's really ever
dead
even if you bite their head off even if
you eat them there's some way to keep
that i mean i think carnage could easily
still be alive oh yeah the question is
cletus yeah guys decapitated so maybe
not
maybe not no unless unless there's some
remnant of him left over inside of
carnage they can use to reclone him or
something but that seems convoluted
for this yeah
oh marina thank you for the little super
sticker it's so delightful little
jumping
character
uh makes me want to jump for joy
thank you marine that's really sweet of
you kwai top films
isn't it funny kiwi top films oh kiwi
top films my bad missed the eye
the screen's all the way over there
isn't it funny how this movie is exactly
like high tops draft
i don't remember high top films i
remember he liked the first venom movie
yeah but i don't remember what his pitch
was because i i do remember that he was
pitching what they should do for the
sequel okay but i don't remember what
his pitch was now i'm curious to go back
and revisit it to see if that is indeed
true
personally out of video essays high top
films is my favorite which i find
which i find kind of funny because
i don't agree with him so much i would
say more often than not i generally do
not agree with high top films
yet he is still my favorite person to
listen to
um and i love his opinions a lot and but
when i do agree with him i like really
agree with him yeah
mike's thoughts about stuff sweet i
haven't seen anyone else notice but the
second where the reality shifts around
venom is the same sound in doctor
strange when his third eye is open oh
really huh
well there's not for sure for sure
there's a compelling piece of evidence
if it's authentic
i mean there's definitely like a
strange sci-fi noise so maybe huh
we need to get up we need to download a
pack of every mcu sound effect so that
we can keep those in order
and then reference them later shadow
skull game happy birthday john yeah joe
where'd it go man greg
thanks it's neither of our birthdays now
but i
feel like it is mine again because of
this comment even though greg's was the
most recent a lot of people in the chat
like man of action is saying an mcu
version of cassidy is still alive
maybe if cletus cassidy is for sure
going to be brought into the mcu mm-hmm
in our mcu um oh my god what's the word
that we use sacred timeline yes that's
not just no secret timeline anymore no
it's not first now um but yeah if there
it may be
but i don't know i think they're gonna
drop it but how cool would it be if they
actually fully realize maximum carnage
dude someday it'll happen
someday somehow
that's right
if you really want to get dislikes in
your video admit this
i [ __ ] love me some nickel pack
i love nickelback that's great and a lot
of people got some enjoyable music that
generic ass rock band but i don't i
personally like how all their songs have
the same structure
same general vibe they're two vibes
there's the there's like
there's chill sentimental uh uh
nickelback and then there's rock and
nickel back yeah
kind of chill
look at this whoa
you know that's a little more chill
mr go big or go home guys i'm seeing
venom tonight what should i expect
everything we've been talking about for
the last hour you should expect some
decent visual effects
decent action quirky comedy left and
right and uh and an alright guy and an
alright guy
olivia d14 moment of silence
muchas
gracias
olivia d14 follow-up could only get on
here for a few minutes and someone
already asked my question so i just want
to remind sean again that he's a cutie
venom
thank you i'm i'm so flattered right now
and i'm a little self-conscious too
uh i love you olivia d14
wcf gray wolf appreciate the moment of
silence thank you dislike the [ __ ]
mission a minute to nickelback dude it's
okay just admit to a band that everyone
loves and you'll be fine so you love
imagine dragons oh [ __ ] imagine dragons
joseph
about nickelback that's right
the original the original the original
the original biggest rock band everyone
seems to somehow hate uh love you guys
says joseph curtis when are you guys
seeing dune
warns i know warren's been invited to
the eternals red carpet trust me i know
and that's got the same email
we got the same email hey corey's in the
chat corey are you going to be at the
eternals coy are you you better be at
eternals koi
we people yo we we've been reading all
the regular super chats my friend it's
just we don't i mean regular chat it's
just we don't uh we don't flash it on
screen it's because we got this big chat
thing yeah yeah
um
we might be seeing dune the first it's
the third week of october
yes right
yeah we just got an update like any time
the week of the
maybe this week or next or something
yeah or we'll just um i think it's next
week or we'll just
watch it here on our arm computer the
way yeah villainy has intended for us to
watch it coy was not invited to the
eternals premiere
coy
dude i'm sorry i'll call the mouse on
your behalf right now
make sure they get you in you you're the
you're the of all of us who would
deserve to be there the most
how was koi not invited that
surprisingly yeah why didn't kevin feige
invite you personally
niraj we don't have an extra spot man
i'm sorry
it's okay dude you can have my spot
hey guys says niraj krishnan love you
buddy how would this uh wha
hey guys
we'll give this movie maybe a six and a
half out of ten cletus cassidy and
shriek annoyed me a lot harrelson and
naomi harris didn't get enough to do i i
agree with that it's weird i i mean
cletus is much more of a presence than
uh francis is than shriek is but at the
same time they both felt under used like
they still had mostly plot [ __ ] to do
like there are little moments for woody
harrelson like when he walks up to the
car and he's like ooh gotta have it
where you're like oh yeah he's getting
to have fun as the character but
especially naomi harris i was like she's
a great actress
and you got her to to
you literally looked at like pirates and
a couple other movies and went oh oh do
that
day should we just answer if we we're
gonna see dune on the third week of
october probably um but i would say that
naomi harris
personally
i think
as much as she was underused
by far
i liked what the the choices she was
making when she had screen time totally
i thought she was like really committed
and i really liked what she was doing
yeah she was also the one in pirates of
the caribbean or that different woman
yeah witty jack okay
which is the way it's good they gave her
a southern accent here because for a
second yeah this is the same character
carnage's voice was okay i didn't think
it was anything special
no
he used it more carnage is a monologue
he doesn't shut the [ __ ] up
yeah he seemed very straightforward by
comparison especially to cletus cassidy
let's move up i need to use the bathroom
in a second oh take it down i really
need to use it i'm ready to take a big
[ __ ] roasting
i'll be 20 minutes john hold the four
down john uh juan guerrales i was
wondering how much do you think
spider-man no way home will make
considering the stellar box office
performance of venom let there be
venom let the re-carnage is expected to
make 800 million spider-man's gonna be
like two billion dollars everybody's
gonna make like
billions gonna make so much money yeah
oh totally a hundred percent if anything
so much about billions
it's gonna be spider-man yeah it's gotta
be like it's gotta make stupid yeah yeah
stupid money i'm calling
and i'm sorry you didn't enjoy thanks
for being here for so long sarah
pandemic jones but sarah we love you
not you panda are you guys looking
forward to dune just kidding do you say
dune or dune
find that youtube video never lose your
nerd what's up buddy what's up buddy it
was a fun and entertaining movie good
not great and definitely should have
been longer love the post credit scene
and love y'all and the live stream
thanks so much
that's very sweet of you never lose
being never lose your nerd it's gonna
make at least two dollars robo ian says
dude it's gonna be so great deadpool why
are you only subscribing now
deadpool we reacted to your reaction
here james bond gets sent into the
multiverse that would be great i think
that should happen then we can have them
all cross over we can get a de-aged uh
deep faked sean connery
we can get timothy dalton back in the
suit we can get uh george lassenby
all the people's favorites i'm gonna run
to the bathroom super super quick i
drank way too much liquid before this
live stream started john hold the fork
down all right shaquando biggums look i
haven't seen any movies with timothy
chalamet either except for
uh lady bird so it's funny everyone
loves the [ __ ] out of that guy
and i'm like
he's fine i've seen him the once and
he's fine
but uh greg loves timothy chalamet he's
here to berate me about it now um also
saw a comment uh about the little sims
cameo being a bit awkward maybe
but don't sleep on lil sims music her
music is [ __ ] awesome and i think
it's very funny
that i i feel like that song venom was
even out on it was on her last
full-length record that dropped before
her most recent full-length record
dropped and so part of me is like
i wonder if they slept on that song and
then found that song and then went all
right now we're gonna co-op that song
but anyway
suffice it to say go listen to some
little sims because she is [ __ ]
awesome
deadpool with the symbiote would be fun
ptx c1 i actually
honestly that would be so much fun and i
feel like they could probably pretty
easily do that you know uh paul mccary
maybe the mcu version of brock killed
uncle ben and peter hates him not vice
versa i would be fascinated
i would be fascinated if they did that i
don't see how it would work logistically
if eddie and venom are just being
blipped into the universe now unless
you're going with a giant
misunderstanding as the linchpin of your
conflict here dude from the 80s is jamie
dove hey that movie is not as bad as it
gets made out to be i mean it's not good
like it's not a successful
movie but uh yeah it it's you know it's
something it's uh it's something uh what
is the name of the song from the wedding
scene linui pro gramista uh is that what
they're doing am i thinking of the right
movie is that when they're doing the
sort of orchestrated version of uh the
it's like a joy division song right or
no uh love will tear us apart is that
joy division i feel like it was uh level
terrace apart
unless i'm thinking too earlier in the
movie
uh but yes got your tickets for dune
already glad people are excited for dune
andrea andy gave venom a nine out of ten
that's pretty good that's pretty good
dune says people
that's all you're doing repeating
comments out loud no we talked about we
talked about the little sims cameo we
talked about this person says eddie we
talked about the little sims cameo we
talked about eddie brock potentially
killing uncle ben in this mcu universe
we've had a whole experience right over
here
uh but yeah don't sleep on little sims
her music is awesome
that's weird i thought we'd get so much
more crap
more uh
expressing honest criticism
i feel like
now i'm like well the most high stakes
part of the of the response to this
movie seems to just be how you feel
about the post-credits scene
you know the rest of the movie it's like
yeah take it or leave it what's
happening one of my nights someone in
the chat's asking about the tone mcguire
elite audio because we put up a video
yesterday where we're reacting to it and
um as exciting as it was
uh um there's a person i follow on
twitter who who's tweeted we i came
across way too late otherwise i would
have been like don't put up this video
because um his name is taran uh taran
singh i think his name a vfx artist and
he's a very really reliable when it
comes to debunking or confirming whether
something is legit or not okay and like
he was the one who did the video of when
he was proving that the garfield video
was just [ __ ] it's a real video yeah
yeah he's really good at that and he was
pretty much i at one point in an art
video yesterday i said there's ways to
manipulate voices and make it sound like
it's toby mcguire but it's not uh and he
was pretty much going out of his way to
prove
that it's not
uh it's not fake
but maybe maybe maybe he's wrong i don't
know all right regardless i believe he's
in it that's it that's the bottom line
yeah bottom line i believe he's in it
yes um yeah would i rather see a hulk
plus deadpool movie or deadpool plus
spiderman movie i feel like for starters
a hulk plus deadpool movie would be it's
a little bit more dynamic well yeah and
it would be a like picking off yeah and
it would be a dynamic that i would be
curious about you know i kind of have my
my ideas of what it would play out like
but that prospect seems a lot more like
what are they going to do please show me
yes
uh okay we're all caught up here uh we
are i mean we're refreshed we got some
new ones to go through we've got some
new ones to go through we got more to
film today so we're going to end the
stream soon okay um but i think we
covered everything this movie's not as
deep no easter egg heavies it's all
plotty very plotty
wcf we got we got a good amount to film
we got like we're not caught up at all
on patreon we got we don't want to knock
out some squid games yeah
we got episode five already shot gotta
edit that and then uh gotta
shoot some more because squid game's
been [ __ ] incredible yeah dude if
you're not watching it you better get
watching it
um so we got one do we need to watch the
chord recruit do we need to react to it
because i was kind of like i feel like
we've already seen enough to believe it
and we've already covered enough of that
i'll watch it mean i want to be glad to
watch it on my own time yeah i love it
i'm like you react to it yeah it's
imperative or can i just put it on the
community page be like everyone watch
this you know
okay so never lose your nerds back what
was the lord of the rings easter egg in
the first 30 seconds
wait a minute john olsen says that
an easter egg of lord of the rings in
the first 30 okay what's the opening
shot of the movie again i don't remember
either i mean it's all the backstory
with uh with uh cletus and and francis
so i was like is something in the prison
is there is there a circle is it just
like there's a circle a ring is it the
ring is the bending ring
i don't know is it how she turns
invisible when she first puts on the
cloth ring yeah
i don't know okay so
let me ask you guys this so for those
who've seen the quarter crew video
you've already seen us react to when
the video came out we've already reacted
to when someone was saying it's fake and
that same video we react it was the
person who trolled it saying was fake
and then we already reacted to
how someone who really made a deep dive
video improving how it's real yes
do we need to watch this corridor crew
video still to what like or is it gonna
do anything new for us yeah is this
gonna we're just gonna be like uh this
just solidifies it some more you know
yeah based on what we've already seen
would there be still stuff to react to
that's new for us yeah yeah because you
know when it comes especially when it
comes to covering other youtubers videos
that really care that we can have
something that generates not just a
reaction but allows us to pause and do
some commentary yeah yeah because
honestly recorder crew i'm like
they're doing it
yeah i'm like it's really hard like i'm
just gonna watch it you know
other than pausing to go well that's a
great point i really appreciate what
they know
gianni i don't know
same thing they just go more in depth
never lose your nerd
is shriek a mutant carnage was a quick
waste
uh shriek says in the opening scene that
she's got this mutation she says
mutation doesn't say mutant which are
very different terms yes they are but
you know yeah i think until the mutants
actually show up anything and everything
that even eludes them you could take as
a hint because at a certain point i'm
sure they
marvel will look back and go all those
things
hints
by the way daesh is always watching has
a great reaction channel go check her
out
yeah share the love
sean turn bring us back here bring the
screen back alive gianni calderon
what
if the venom symbiote already attached
to andrew garfield's spider-man and
that's why he hates tom holland's
spider-man that would be very convoluted
or toby's or another spider-man that we
don't know about it still wouldn't be
personal to tom holland tom holland
himself would be like what's going on
why do you hate me yeah stop it
uh
yeah oh man i really think they missed
the mark there on carnage and shriek i i
really feel like that's my biggest
letdown oh man and it would have been a
much cooler movie yeah it could have
don't worry this is just a fascinating
character that's why
well
they make that whole thing about like
people love serial killers and getting
to know them we're not going to do that
in this movie
oh i put my creative footage pro con
chat in case
you guys were serious oh yeah it would
be fun to check out oh my goodness i i
gotta scroll back up and find that or
you can send it again and and let us
know
jiko i would rather have vet mb in the
mcu than the amazing spider-man unit
yeah just to answer your questions i
think anything going to the mcu is a lot
more fun of a prospect a lot of things
are down right now instagram was down
earlier i couldn't unload our gmail
earlier yeah facebook i hear is down
according to the chat i was like
twitter's down to everything down you
got instagram [ __ ] to do today i don't
like can't access any of that so do you
think silk uh
jigoku nico do you think silk will join
them or appear in a post-credits scene
as her show is in development from the
same studio
no i don't think they i mean i don't
think she'll be in a post-credits scene
no i feel like it's just
it's just i think it's his early
development stage for the silk right now
yeah
uh why not though just why not [ __ ]
throw everyone in there who gives a [ __ ]
everybody's in the next post we're all
excited anyways [ __ ] doing it
at avengers 10 game level event we'll
just put it in a post-credits scene
everyone's here
wcf grey wolf is back what if venom
chose the god of mischief now that
is an episode i want to see
venom loki it would be cool to have
venom in the mcu so we could do
something
[ __ ] with whatever that's what i want
in season two that would be pretty cool
that would be wicked get on it disney
spider-man no wait facebook home
mike t
5 4 um
okay twitter ain't down
while while i enjoyed the movie i have a
few gripes shriek was pointless in my
opinion and carnage's voice should have
been a higher pitch
i didn't really have an expectation for
carnage's voice i just wanted there to
be a personality or a life to it i had a
little expectation like i was surprised
they went deep really yeah i always
associate yeah with just like a more
erratic shrill kind of maniacal voice
something that's a little a little at
least a little in this range or
something even kind of to the ward the
higher than that like joker
yeah i wanted to talk just like this
like goblin yeah
yeah i mean there's a lot that's the
problem too is you run into a lot of a
lot of overlap but uh yeah it isn't
carnage lack personality that was my
main thing i don't really care which
direction you take the pitch of the
voice it was just more the personality
yeah i know i mean the the the stuff he
says is very straightforward and very
sort of
i don't know there's no bombast or glee
or mania to it you know i mean putting
putting just the symbiote alone in the
mcu can be [ __ ] awesome for some
action scenes yeah dude
yep the possibilities to be attached to
like hulk or something you know how cool
would that be like all of the
possibilities are are interesting to me
on that front
doo doo doo venom absorbs the marvel
universe and just everyone's got a
symbiote i i know most people like like
t von t novak's in the chat is saying
how
um
he really uh he thought the voice should
have been higher pitch and i think a lot
of people share that same sentiment um
it's a common sentiment that i'm just
like i didn't really care about the
pitch you just
personality i think you're ultimately
right is like if it had been the same
dialogue with a different pitch i would
probably
share your complaints still you know
whereas if it had been better dialogue
and the same pitch then whatever you
know it's better dialogue the cloth ring
he calls her my precious that's what it
is i did notice that yeah
yeah yeah he says precious i did yeah
thank you sarah williams i just didn't
remember it
past that moment sean mclaughlin oh yeah
big dick here
a big bag duck hair in scotland swearing
is like poetry i've already watched that
clip so many times during bad times and
tonight he's gave me another lift thank
you
it's my excellent scottish so scottish
voice for you
the post-credits seat is such a savior
for this movie
because in all the heavy lifts even for
people who didn't like the movie they're
like but that post courtesy i want to
know
like what people would have thought of
it had it not had the scene yeah if they
if if there was like a version where
nobody got to see it
because you know i feel like opinions
that's the blu-ray cut
no post-credits scene included
yeah we don't want marvel to sell their
dvds
all right hulk smash yo mom venom was
good not great
love you guys
that comment was great
i love you all right
let's refresh this all right um
would you mind just hurting it off kill
the supers
no questions guys we're ending this
super chats right now but i appreciate
it no kryptonians no lanterns no super
carnage can be resurrected z hyrule
yeah anything there's a possibility man
there's a definite possibility don't you
worry about it they can do absolute
carnage
do you think the sentence responsibility
is me for the mediocre from venom 2 it
was an easter egg for spider-man
absolutely
absolutely it was
what a great comment they're like where
are you gonna be making a mediocre movie
was an easter egg reference to the
amazing spiderman
that's right dude that's right
there's a way to justify everything with
great power comes the ability to be
mediocre that's a funny ass comment i
really appreciate that thank you yes
youtube i understand the implications of
turning off the super chats
will survive
venom
got the adrenaline momentum
you know what i realized on the way to
the first screening is that uh i like
the venom song that eminem did like i
listened to it i understand what's silly
about it
i still like to listen to it and when
i'm listening to it i'm like this is
good it's still kind of fun though i'm
glad he committed but at the same time
you know what i learned
is
it's impossible
to attempt to sing along with the chorus
and not devolve into giggles try it try
to keep your breath and try to hit the
rhyme scheme that he's hitting and you
can't do it without giggling
you know venom got that adrenaline
momentum
[Music]
ain't gonna slow up and i'm fixing to go
on him
like
he's saying words he sees there are
words in there i've looked them up every
time i've listened to the song lately
because they're impossible to remember
because you can't it's like usually you
hear a lyric or you read it and then you
can hear where it forms
and it's not the case
[Music]
okay where do we leave off in the super
chats crown crown got crown yeah all
right
so we go up right to logan john people
really liking your scottish one oh
thanks i'm gonna do it all in scottish
from now on
do we read crown or do we do we we did
crown okay we did crowns the next is
logan wright logan lucky lerman
the way venom licks the screen and says
that guy was like he knew him do you
think one of the things venom
experienced while traveling the universe
was an altercation with a spider-man
maybe
this symbiote is the one from spider-man
3 and it survived or something so i
don't like that
all right it's been rob a couple times
i don't like it
i like this i i want it to just be a
personal vendetta he has
it's
tom holland maybe okay eddie brock maybe
maybe you could do that borrow it for to
make to have it apply for venom and
maybe venom has had like bad experiences
with bad spiderman
but uh i think eddie brock and peter
parker specifically i don't know why
they won't like it i don't know why
eddie brock will hate tom holland
there's got to be a reason why unless
they're skipping all that and going
right to some team-up movie
lethal protectors
let's do it
maybe karna should be resurrected and
spider-man needs spider-man's help maybe
carnage can attach to spider-man i mean
that would be cool yeah
you get the spider-man carnage thing
yeah and then you could have you know at
least a reason for them to fight yeah
slim shady in the chat what's up slim
shady 104
honored to have you here beard's weird
maybe loki caused the multiverse but
doctor strange is the one that converged
them bringing in the villains you guys
are [ __ ] things up man
i am like once doctor strange two
finally drops i am gonna be like okay is
it some combo because right now i mean
it's that it's that debate of is a
doctor strange spell is it sylvie and
then there's like two people in the back
who are like or maybe it's kang
you know
i wonder if maybe there is some kind of
one-two punch of like ah now
because of what sylvie did and now
doctor strange it's like you know the
ripple effects of decisions and whatnot
it's like i guess suppose you know this
post-credit scene is not something
that's ultimately surprising to me
because it just seemed like it was a
matter of time right
from the get-go yeah it seemed like it
was a matter of time because people
already knew that like spider-man was
part of
sony yeah ultimately he was being
borrowed
so just a matter of time
i think when things will really be a
game changer is when you see like doctor
strange you got like a [ __ ] charles
xavier in there or something yeah you're
like oh crap now we're really doing this
yeah or spider-man actually nah that's
still sony just impossible yeah still
game changer though still a game changer
we're doing game changers right it's
yeah franchise game changing it's not
the biggest of the game changers
recently but it's still a game changer
maybe you've had him just knew about
spider-man from watching the news
i just really hate this i just really
hate a man
he is a menace i agree i don't know why
everyone thinks venom knows spider-man
seems like venomous reaction to seeing
spider-man was like a kid seeing a candy
commercial when he said that guy he
could just be saying that guy
i don't think i want that guy that guy
give it to me why would he just say that
guy yeah
i don't know unless he's just really
judging his appearance alone he's like
oh this guy he's got such a punchable
face
eatable head
popcorn
hi
i had fun with the movie greg what is
your hair care routine you both have
such nice hair a shower
it depends on the day and the weather
yeah sometimes if it's just used like
conditioner
i comb it in the shower yeah
and then if i really want to take my
time i put it up in a sweater but if i'm
rushing like i am most days i just
drive with a sweater
and then you gotta get at the right time
the right time the right time and nine
times out of ten i don't get the right
time oh so i'm wearing beanies a lot
because i don't get the right time
you put some type of like
clay in there
and then you scrunch it then you comb it
and then you scrunch
shake
and then you see what happens
and then
then i go all right put it on a beanie
or all right i'm gonna wear my hair out
i guess do a hair tutorial for the
channel one of those like walk throughs
about like here's how i do my hair you
just take a little scrunch of this in
your palm and you know
do the greg on april fool's 2022 is what
you should put up that video i lived
with john for a year there were plenty
of times you could just wake up film
didn't need to do any hair thing you
just sometimes roll out of bed walk to
that chair
it's beneficial correct set up
everything
yeah i mean that's that's i guess the
benefits of of of being a lot when you
have long hair you're locked into like
one or two steps long straight hair
that's true yeah when you don't have the
curls to connect yeah through the waves
or anything like that
maybe this is that guy because maybe
just maybe he bonded with peter when he
had a fight with eddie it's sort of an
apartment it's a stretch but a
possibility he's just mainly a strong
dimension hopped
got on peter parker had a whole spat and
then came back
yeah i like that we'll go with that
wait who's next here
we gotta film some [ __ ] john
nathan all right is the last of the uh
stream labs i believe and then we'll
check the last of the super chats does
anyone realize nathan asks that they
just confirmed venom for no way home he
isn't in the trailer not the lizard i
really oh he is in the trailer we talked
about this in yesterday's video i really
doubt that in venom three it will be
about him and spiderman no i think venom
venom is not i don't think that's venom
in the no way home trailer i don't
confident that the lizard
it just makes way more sense for what
they're doing with that movie it seems
like everybody they want to involve has
a purse and it would make only that much
so like you have a bit of a skew in that
it seems like you would have maybe
three villains from the tobey mcguire
universe for each of those movies so
maybe you would miss out on having one
for tom holland but it seems like right
now yeah you get a couple for toby a
couple from andrew and then a couple
from tom holland and it's like you know
venom isn't attached to anybody right
now so it would feel more like uh let's
shove this popular character in here
rather than something that is fitting
currently with the theme of this
crossover they're doing it's definitely
a lizard a lot of people think it's
venom
warren was pointing out because they're
like you don't see a tail
but it could be obscured in darkness
see barely hit anything in that shot to
begin with
i think it's and then something hits
when he turns something hits the uh you
know with that doctor strange invisible
door
pretty sure that's a tale of team and
i'm pretty sure it's delicious war like
how elijah in the chat sing i'm pretty
sure it's literally roar
would just make the most sense i feel
like
pandas says to refresh the
streamlabs oh yeah we doing it we
refreshing we doing one last round of
refreshes before we boogie
on out of here and what we'll do is
we'll finish the stream uh we'll finish
the stream labs
we finish the super chats up i think
there is a tail yeah i agree with you
cam kay
maybe he cut off his tail
do you guys think venom from spider-man
3 is the same venom from venom i hope so
yes i hope what topher grace put out on
the internet is a hundred percent true
yeah totally topher knows all right he
recuts so many movies alan tudyk would
have been a great cletus cassidy that's
actually not a bad oh my god that would
have been perfect
dang
i am we're refreshing it panda we are
refreshing we are refreshing don't you
worry panda yes
we will go there all righty all righty
let's go up we got mike t so we're at
flaming angel g
j
f
goseth jordan levitt
did we do this one from miket54
oh i don't think so no you gotta have a
good memory about these people who are
saying that's not your customer service
you've read some mic t54 already so
that's why oh you're an excuse i am
giving an excuse because mike t is just
too generous the fact that you were
about to skip over i accidentally wanted
to skip over you intentionally
maliciously even
also i'm not grateful just
thought of this but what if part of
venom attached itself to flash in the
mcu
to flash flash thompson okay
i was like wait a minute what
oh gotcha that's how he got blonde and
maybe we could get an anti-venom slash
agent venom
i mean sure
they feel like they gotta do something i
mean i've kind of always liked how flash
was a little bit more normal you know
what i mean yeah
yeah i suppose they should keep them
that way no everyone should become a
super thing by the end of it i think
there's something to unpack there with
flash thompson
who's always bullied peter parker but is
idolizes spider-man yeah now that he
knows spider-man is really peter parker
there's there's some great scene there
i'm hoping they truly mine
for
spider-man no way home yeah i hope they
just like do like a one or two jokes i
hope they actually have like an actual
scene between them like character
development
but who knows what the [ __ ] do i know
right what the [ __ ] do i know
why did they shift the ang character
from being strong the first one being
the typical damsel in the stress she's
strong here she goes then stands up to
venom yeah and then she's even like man
it's so fun to be venom too like she's
clearly got spunk yeah
flaming angel
gjf do you think she thinks of venom
when dan makes love to her oh abs no she
thinks of tom holland this is parker
almost exactly what i said a few minutes
ago
do it read it did you copy me or do i
copy you what if they go the absolute
carnage route and resurrect carnage and
hunt down all the people who have worn a
symbiote okay i didn't consider that
part about huntington people warn a
symbiote but i totally think there's a
way to resurrect carnage
carnage specifically i don't cletus is
another story
uh yeah that opens up a whole new avenue
there for the sony spider-man universe
whatever the [ __ ] it's called to think
is that what it's called is it is the
sony spider-man universe now or is just
that that plain and simple i liked it it
was more complicated i couldn't remember
you wanted the spunk
there's so many pictures of marvel
characters
uh way better so do spider-man universe
so the ssu yes okay the sue sounds like
a [ __ ] navy seal boat yeah maybe
still ship the yes that's you it's the
ssu
shipping out to battle
say goodbye sailor
wave goodbye to your sweetheart at home
who says yes that's you you won't be
seeing her till we hit the next port
in bermuda
um
i mean you got to establish more
symbiotes first right unless they but
knowing sony they would probably just do
like [ __ ] it we got a whole bunch more
simon's out there yeah but they do don't
they are there other symbiotes out there
absolutely well i've only seen the first
venom movie one
time yeah i think i have no i think i
maybe saw it a second time
how many times i see him
uh yeah cause in the first one i can't
remember if you see any kind of like
division because you have the one that
becomes riot traveling for like
months on end
so it's like through that logic and the
fact that yeah there's like one that
gets riot and there's one that becomes
venom i'm like oh maybe who knows did
you guys notice that the actors so
awesome i just lost the comment it's
okay i was somewhat that too someone
said
that uh all the actors who play venom of
a t.o in there
like topher topher tom
and and hey
somebody said tony
todd is tony todd and it's here we go
azeem says did you guys know these the
actors from venom have t.o in their name
toby grace tom hardy now tony todd can't
wait to see tony todd's iteration
did i miss something where tony todd
candyman has been cast as venom
oh my god
john does not know this
i could yeah you don't tell me todd is
venom don't have your finger on the
pulse tony todd tony handyman voicing oh
all right that makes sense
venom okay
in in
an animated movie jesus christ john fill
in the blank spider-man no way home
no an animated movie how do you know
video game
what video game oh oh in spider-man 2
gotcha okay
with venom
in the trailer
and the game's going to be much darker
see i keep seeing those reports about
like venom spider-man 2 like this game
is going to be darker than the first
game
that's what i know yeah i didn't know
tony todd was going to voice venom i'm
sorry and he's got double the the thing
you pointed out he's got t-o-t-o which
he's a perfect choice too let's read
bradley both so it's common okay bb
what's up bb hey guys hope you're doing
good baby
bradley bless so baby hey guys i don't
think you slept much yesterday me yeah i
tried yeah me too i tried to sleep hey
guys so we're doing well my sleep is so
[ __ ] up right now i hope you're doing
well do you think it would be possible
that venom knows who spidey is because
he linked his memory with the rainbow
verse venom i think yeah that's 100
what's happening we got to change the
tune to the live stream sam raimi
confirmed it sam raimi did come out this
is a breaking scoop guys yeah scoops
galore here yeah that's that's our uh
scoop name scoops galore check us out on
patreon um scoop score
the hottest
all the hottest entities scoops the
venom they're they're bringing they
don't want to bury the events of
spider-man 3 from that venom no it's a
reboot goes we have to honor the venom
that game sam raimi so they're going to
bring back the toe for grace sam raimi
just gave a two-hour talk on on a
podcast saying that he did that
intentionally with spider-man because
this is always the plan people riled us
always they wouldn't anticipate that
venom returning he was the original
fighter remember that context of toby
mcguire because that's what's going to
create the few to tom holland yeah yeah
oh no this was planned out years in
advance yeah sam raimi had the original
idea for the mcu and you know eventually
kevin feige took it yeah kevin feige is
a fraud yeah kevin fraud the guy kevin
froddy
yeah michael smith i hate this garbage
is coming to my perfect mcu
i'm sorry buddy i mean maybe in the
hands of the mcu it'll be handled better
if it is in the hands of the mcu i have
a feeling they're gonna put spider-man
in venom three i think they are gonna do
that so that way they control this movie
so so the idea is that the postcards
yeah
that the post-credits scene is basically
going spider-man and venom will meet and
venom is in the mcu except we're only
going to see that in the context of the
sony universe yeah
i think that's like the same way how we
have vulture
yes in morbius it's a one-way sliding
door where it's like tom holland can
come back and forth and everybody else
just stays on the venom side yeah all
right all right i don't think [ __ ]
[ __ ] wants this stuff in their mcu i
i want but that's what's more exciting
to me is to see it blend there than
seeing because like of course because
what everyone thinks but i'm like i
don't think that's what's happening and
if i'm wrong thank god yeah i don't
think this is happening everybody else
coming over to sony is like well i don't
know that could be anything you know i
don't have a baseline of quality to
expect there
i just have erratic that's the thing
right now is that because these venom
movies have been so weird as to be
messy but somehow
enjoyable in in exactly the right ways
i'm like i don't i don't know what to
think of morbius or any of these other
movies like are they gonna be equally
messy i don't know but you know the mcu
tends to have this similar
cinematography i'm liking how when i
watch venom one and two in the morbius
trailer that those have a similar
cinematography absolutely i just want
homogeny from all my universes everett
everett pixel mike baker thank you for
the sticker yeah a little pear guy hey
you check out the stream labs really
quick and then you also can refresh this
i will always refresh everything
we
are venom we are mrs chatham
[Music]
[ __ ] andrew garfield has set himself
up to just uh
just be a cute to never have his word
trusted ever again i know every
interview now if you were just going to
give him crap
all righty
let's see peter's identity being
revealed do you think they are
overcomplicating things with venom
inclusion i don't know we might not
[ __ ] see how this pays off for like
another three four years so it doesn't
really matter they'll figure it out
okay nathan we got did we get non-pics n
uh non p fiction i hope dan's a villain
of venom three
and just regular guy no symbiotes
attached to him or anything like that
it's just him and he's kind of a dull
husband
uh non-pic fiction so in the end with
the detective we see his eyes glow
basically as the introduction of toxin
symbiote but venom being transported to
mcu
is that just wasted now
no i don't think so
i don't think so at all
it's gonna be something i feel like
they've all got to be transported in
some way right
it's either that or venom's gonna get
transported back or something everyone's
really championing for that toxin movie
everyone really wants that talk this is
a solo movie let's do it i didn't even
understand how he became toxin in this
movie i i didn't either and i know that
there's twice how'd it happen
his eyes turn a color yeah i saw that
that's how that happened
you don't see a [ __ ] and i asked koi
about it and i was like well this seems
like a weird
this doesn't
commun
compute
with the other symbiosis processes we've
seen in this world so far and he said he
seemed to think that maybe they're going
for a more advanced sort of futurized
iteration of the symbiotes from the
comics cory just loves everything
loves everything
well on his birthday he doesn't like
that movie it's i looked at his mcu
ranking on his letterbox and it is like
third from the bottom
wow and i asked him i was like let me
get this straight doctor strange is like
one of your lowest ranked mcu films and
he raised a good point which at least
for his sake he said you know that
basically what they did with the doctor
strange movie is essentially make iron
man again but with steven strange
because a lot of the beats and character
dynamics of who steven strange is and
what he has to go through being humbled
and then ultimately uh you know losing
everything building himself back up is
like very similar to iron man and so he
didn't think it was a special enough
story especially given how uh the comic
world is
now we could take time here i
this is the uh
this is the paraphrasing koi's review
live stream now the toxin will be back
toxin will absolutely be back
toxin will live on don't you wreck
all right logan right one of i believe
two yeah in the after credit scenes
venom gets moved to the mcu while
peter's identity is being revealed which
means it couldn't have been dr strange's
spell that brought him since it would
have been happening yet do you feel it's
some
bigger something bigger at play you said
there's two
yes
i just realized guys if it's a hive mind
what if the symbiote hive mind connects
across multiverses and that's why venom
knows spider-man because he has those
memories of what's happened to his
multiverse self yes
that is
that's 100 what we've been saying is a
major possibility when he says that guy
we were gonna break down for years to
come that guy what that guy
really means when he says it hour long
video on that guy
i would love for the opening of venom
three to be like you said you knew him
and he's i did not say he knew him i
said that guy yeah but why'd you say
that guy because he sounded like you
knew him no i just said that's god you
clearly implied that you knew him no i
just thought he had an interesting
costume
we should get a costume
i told you you had that covered
maybe you're right we won't know for a
while but i would love for the sony just
to come out and [ __ ] spoil it anyway
but i agree i don't think it's from
doctor strange's spell specifically no i
feel like
maybe
it could maybe it could be it could be
but i feel like it's a silvie thing it
just seems like it would be a sylvie
thing i think venom and spider-man
that's the direction they're headed that
they will eventually team up but i they
gotta start with rivalry or maybe
they'll do a captain america civil war
thing where they start off as
friends allies before they become foes
yeah and then peter finds out that venom
killed uncle ben and aunt may knew about
it all along and then they have a big
fight i guess i would want a toxin solo
movie but at the same time here i'm like
uh
as as good of an actor as [ __ ] um
steven graham is
i don't really want to see a solo movie
of this guy
no
i don't know i mean i feel like doing a
solo movie of a symbiote is you do venom
or or
maybe carnage if you want to go the
opposite route and do an anti-hero thing
but i feel like the rest of them are
propped up by having venom or spider-man
around it's kind of weird to do like
symbiote
spin-off movies
yeah because like it's just like a bunch
of like it looks the same yeah it's like
the same concept of the character and if
you're just trying to spin them all off
it's going to be like the same dynamics
of like either they have to go up
against another super thing or you just
got to watch as somebody thwarts them i
don't know mulligan got infected because
he was stabbed with a piece of carnage
okay i mean that again so everyone who's
been stabbed is a possibility of
becoming a symbiote that simple
i i guess
yeah what are the rules
everyone who seems to have an answer for
some things i i often go
wait wait a minute wait a minute i don't
understand what you're saying i don't
get it yeah
i don't know i i i don't know i don't
know i don't know if a toxin yeah like
it's it's always possible but i feel
like the whole point is that he's
introduced in this movie to get you
hyped about like oh man this guy's got a
relationship with eddie brock and now
he's his own symbiote it's got to be
it's got to be a problem
bye guys
bye
right there end of the live stream
guys if the deadpool came into the
universe in the dc universe [ __ ] me
well then we will if he ever does we
will have sex with you all right guys
we're gonna end this stream right now
yes we will we didn't get a shrek cameo
i know i'm sorry no
next one venom three maximum shrek we
got a film for okay sean mclaughlin now
let's just read it john
sean mclaughlin
john can you sign off tonight with a
scottish accent
channel your inner william wallace mel
gabson and let out for freedom
i even got a little our role in there
not very good at the art roles i'm
afraid i'm getting better
you can do it sign off
guys
guys thank you for joining us today on
the venom let there be carnage live
stream
thanks for all your theories support and
love and we'll catch you on the next one
you stay sexy
and now
now i'm gonna end
this [ __ ] stream
right
thank you guys so much for being here
love you it was fun dissecting us yeah
probably won't talk about venom let
there be carnage for another week nope
talked about it all right you'll get
spiderman no way home uploads seven days
in a row seven and a half days a week
non-stop because all we do is talk about
more only cosmic wonder
all right guys thank you so much for
being here thanks for everyone to
contribute to the super chat everything
like that but more importantly just
thanks for tuning in regardless for
being here thank you guys so much that's
good we'll see you guys soon peace
we done we're done